pas de lait maudit la cnhi picot sur les
étagères de cette pharmacie et a priori
dans aucune autre pharmacie de
martinique sauf cas exceptionnel les
deux grossistes de lille ne
commercialisent tout simplement pas ses
références dans l'hexagone ce sont les
laits infantiles issu d'une usine située
en espagne qui pose problème de l'eau de
l'est maudit lac à base de protéines de
riz ont transmis la salmonellose à
quatre nourrissons
aujourd'hui ils vont mieux mais la
société sodie lac rappel quatre cent
mille boîtes de 18 références
différentes et par précaution lactalis
rappel elle aussi dans la foulée ses
produits issus de la même usine
les laits infantiles picot ar bas on a
très peu de risques de rencontrer
d'acheter seul et la martinique mais le
risque zéro n'existant pas il faut être
au courant du retrait et éventuellement
procéder à un retrait si vous en avez
chez vous du coup n'a elle n'existe plus
en martinique depuis la sphère de 2017
et
les pharmaciens n'ont pas de
de l'epic oar à vendre en martinique
puisque il y en a plus sur le marché
bon bien sûr il peut avoir des imports
venant individuel de venant de métropole
pour le moment les pharmaciens regrette
tout de même l'absence d' alerte
sanitaire officielle pour mody lac
concernant le les pico ar le protocole
est en revanche très clair on procède au
retrait immédiat du production en picot
anti reflux code traite à informer les
consommateurs en affichant dans votre
point de vente la fiche consommateurs
qui sera disponible sur le site de
l'ordre des pharmaciens à compter de
lundi 28 janvier matin les pharmacies et
supermarchés de martinique ne vendent
pas ses produits mais si vous êtes
malgré tout en possession de boîtes de
lait picot à air ou maudit lac à base de
protéines de riz il ne faut surtout pas
les utiliser